sa ferme laitière continue de produire à
plein régime un geste patriotique selon
les bloch keane
il faut s'assurer de nourrir les
ukrainiens dit il c'est un enjeu
stratégique
la production agricole ukrainienne un
des greniers du monde souffrent déjà de
la guerre champ bombardé et minet dans
l'est ukrainien difficultés
d'approvisionnement en pétrole des
problèmes qui font craindre le pire à la
proche de la saison des semences le
gouvernement ukrainien a demandé à tous
les fermiers de redoubler d'efforts afin
de nourrir le pays mais aussi de
poursuivre les exportations importante
source de revenus pour l'ukraine comment
les autorités locales évaluent en ce
moment nos stocks et besoins en pétrole
est moulé ainsi que notre niveau
possible de production explique-t-il
l'ukraine est un des principaux pays
exportateurs de céréales et de grains
des économistes redoutent une baisse de
l'approvisionnement mondial de l'ordre
de 5 à 10% cette année en raison de la
guerre le spectre de la crise
alimentaire dans les pays déjà
vulnérables d'afrique du nord et du
moyen-orient est bien réelle
l'egypte nourris au blé ukrainien est
secoué le pays importe 70% de ses
besoins en céréales de russie et
d'ukraine
le pain et le couscous fabriqué à partir
du blé sont au coeur de l'alimentation
égyptienne le prix des matières
premières agricoles a augmenté de 30% en
un an et les exportations ukrainiennes
sont maintenant menacés
nous allons subir des pénuries admet ce
fermier ses réserves de blé pour 80
seront épuisés dans deux à trois mois
en italie une pénurie de moules et pour
les animaux pointe déjà à l'horizon des
fermiers commence à envisager des
mesures extrêmes
l'abattage d'animaux faute de nourriture
pour eux une décision lourde de
conséquences rebâtir le cheptel bovin
italien pourrait ensuite prendre jusqu'à
huit
dans sa quête des puits et d'armes
supplémentaires le président ukrainien
appelle les élus italiens à prévenir la
famine qui guette plusieurs pays en
raison de la guerre en ukraine in high
tech richard good est mort il ne pouvons
pas prévoir le niveau de nos
exportations respectives
les blues kenny promet de faire tout ce
qu'il peut tant que ça ferme ne sera pas
bombardé il prendra les armes à ce
moment là s'il le faut des peines
l'impensable il n'y a pas si longtemps
la réalité de tous les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui si philippe le blason canada
stars y arrête chef en ukraine